today we're going to hear from three
republican election officials including
two who say they heard directly from
former president trump trying to
convince them to overturn the 2020
election results so that he could stay
in power scott mcfarlane is once again
following all this closely for us on
capitol hill scott good morning hey tony
good morning to you the committee has
already said it believes donald trump
was part of a conspiracy to defraud the
united states and it says a component of
that plan was this unprecedented
coercion of local election officials to
change the results and throw the
presidency to trump
in the days and weeks before rioters
stormed the capitol the committee says
it was state officials who were feeling
the pressure from then president trump
and his allies they were basically
trying to get state legislators to
not certify the winner of the election
but certify the loser donald trump
today the committee will call three
republican witnesses to try to make that
case
georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger had this call with trump
i just want to find 11
780 votes raffensburger's deputy gabriel
sterling in arizona state house speaker
rusty bowers who says he was called by
trump and rudy giuliani in november 2020
urging him to change the state's
electors which he rejected also
appearing is juandrea shea moss a
georgia election worker targeted by
donald trump who falsely claimed she
carried out a fake ballot scheme the
committee says the pressure campaign on
her and the local officials put them in
danger he faced a lot of threats and
this was a tragic common denominator
that people that got in donald trump's
way people that stood up and confronted
that big lie he was telling
had their lives turned upside down death
threats death threats absolutely armed
protesters outside their homes
as trump continues to make baseless
claims about the election his former
vice president mike pence remains a
focal point he only had this to say
about january 6 at a speech in chicago
monday you know we've all been through a
lot over the last several years
a global pandemic
social unrest
a divisive election a tragic day in our
nation's capital but the committee says
it's still seeking an interview with
pence and hasn't ruled out a subpoena
the committee's investigation is
widening it very much wants to speak
with jenny thomas wife of supreme court
justice clarence thomas about her
communication with local election
officials including in arizona where
they say she was part of a pressure
campaign to overturn the results
tony
could be an interesting conversation
scott thank you very much